Breaking Bad is arguably one of the best
and most talked about shows ever
but while the principal cast have mostly
all gone on to high visibility projects
some of the actors who played minor
roles of had trouble finding their way
out of the ABQ Julia mineski Julie
mineski landed the role of Wendy
Jessie's customer and occasional
paramour for hire only as a result of a
midlife crisis turning 50 thing
according to an interview she did with
AMC she was so convincing as a
prostitute that a guy supposedly drove
up and tried to proposition her while
they were shooting a scene for the show
unfortunately Breaking Bad wasn't the
career catapult she thought it might be
with only one other short film credit to
her name in the six years since she
started the show her turn is the root
beer and meth letting hooker of the
crosswinds Motel may have turned out to
be just a flash in the pan
mariusz Stan after playing walter
white's mean boss buck dan at the a18
car wash mario Stan hasn't had any
active work since Breaking Bad but
that's okay he's actually a real-life
scientist with a PhD in chemistry who
works as a senior computational energy
scientist at Argonne National Laboratory
outside of Chicago probably beats
running a car wash Lavelle Crawford
comedian Lavelle Crawford played Kuehl
who was basically a one joke character
as the enforcer for crooked lawyer Saul
Goodman he barely spoke a word on the
show but still managed to be hilarious
in every scene his post Breaking Bad
credits don't most much but they do
include roles in American ultra and the
Adam Sandler movie the ridiculous six RJ
Mitte before becoming a breakfast loving
son of Walter White RJ Mitte had a kind
of sporadic acting career like a few
background roles in Hannah Montana he
since moved on to switched at birth a
series on ABC Family and landed a few
movie roles but we're still holding up
for middie to land a cooking show where
he just makes breakfast every episode
seriously we binge watch this guy eating
pancakes and eggs for hours Matt Jones
landing a string of roles on network TV
shows like NCIS and mom after Breaking
Bad engine Matt Jones first won our
hearts as badger Jesse's scratchy voiced
underling
I want to be a knight these days he's
got the role of pig on the Nickelodeon
show pig goat banana cricket man first
badger now pig he was like a one-man zoo
Charles Baker skinny Pete was half at
the comic relief duo who sporadically
showed up in various henchman roles for
both
Sen Walter although he played a
spaced-out meth addict Charles Baker is
actually a classically trained stage
performer and an accomplished pianist in
real life as demonstrated by his
beautiful playing in the episode hazard
pay
you sound great
after Breaking Bad he did some work on
mainstream shows like NBC's the
blacklist but he since turned his
attention to independent film work like
the sci-fi thriller approaching the
unknown and Nicolas Winding reference
2016 film the neon demon those are
probably creatively fulfilling projects
for sure but toss some of those names
out to a general audience and they're
gonna look badly to you like you just
recited badger and skinny Pete's Star
Trek pitch I'm on the Starship
Enterprise Mackinac and yeoman Ram while
the enduring with the disruptors back on
Talos 4 or whatever thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which Breaking Bad character you
liked the most
you